[Applaudissements]
peut-être qu'on l'a jamais des marchés
c'est tout si tu es là une empathie
naturelle
une générosité et une sincérité qui fait
du bien et alors moi je ne supporte pas
dans ton propos c'est que ça aurait été
un homme qui aurait jamais fait ce oui
évidemment mais bien sûr et voilà c'est
en tout cas écoute moi j'y reviens comme
ça à son âge mon pas blonde parce que je
[Applaudissements]
n'ai pas à faire ça lui allait plutôt
pas mal de familles noires alors que
miguel de rennes s'est pris un râteau
vient non seulement attention attention
mais reconnaît quand même que miguel
c'est quand même quelqu'un aussi bien
dans toute une histoire que le matin
dans c'est au programme
tu as l'impression qu'elle fait une
réunion chez elle et qu'elle pose des
questions que tout le monde se poserait
à des invités qui sont variés une bande
de copains qui parlent des sujets de la
vie quotidienne of que vous avez une
vraie qualité comme un hymne et sauf que
le voir vous la voulez sincère et pas
moi moi j'ai l'impression de vue devant
ma télé je ne connais absolument parler
des deux aînés nés entre guillemets une
fausse gentille alors pas dû tenir
dimanche gens la regardent
je vous donne mon sentiment de
téléspectateurs sentiment depuis